arbitrage
it's the process of going to a market
buying and selling a bunch of stuff in
such a way that you are guaranteed to
make a profit without taking any risk
and as you might expect such
opportunities are extremely hard to find
in traditional markets and virtually
impossible to find for individuals like
you and me who don't have the backing of
a hedge fund
recently however a new type of market
has emerged as a university experiment
in new zealand it's called predict it
and it allows you to bet on political
outcomes
from who's going to win the next
election to what the next decision of
the supreme court is going to be
and there are two key characteristics
that distinguish this market from the
rest first
big institutional players are not
allowed on predicted
and second people there are how to put
this
very opinionated about politics
and you put these two factors together
you'll get a market that is very ripe
for arbitrage opportunities
and if you come in with some basic math
and a lot of common sense you can really
profit from this
in this video i will show you exactly
how to identify and take advantage of
arbitrage opportunities on this website
and if you feel adventurous
you can even create an account there
deposit a few dollars and take advantage
of these arbitrage opportunities with
some real money
but of course that is not a prerequisite
for this video if you're just here to
have fun enjoy the process and learn
along the way
and i should say that this video is
intended for people who are not
necessarily familiar with arbitrage or
with the platform predicted but if you
are feel free to jump directly to the
section that interests you
but i strongly encourage you though to
follow with me so
let us now jump to this website
predicted.org and see what kind of
markets they offer over there
let's click on the market tab because
that's where all the fun happens and
let's click on the ui selections
and here we can see a list of all the
markets that you can bet on each one of
them is tied to a specific political
event
let's click on this one for example
in this market you can bet on which part
you think is going to be or not be the
winner of the 2024 u.s presidential
election there are multiple parties you
can choose from and in fact if you look
closely each party has two contracts
associated with it a yes contract and a
no contract
let us look at the democrats for example
if you think that the democrats have
good chances of winning the white house
in 2024 you can buy a yes contract at 55
cents by the election of 2024 two things
can happen either the democrats win the
election in which case you will win one
dollar leaving you with a 45 cent profit
or they don't in which case you lose
your initial 55 cent investment
if on the other hand you don't think
they're likely to win you can buy a no
contract so you pay 46 cents up front
and by the election of 2024 if you are
right meaning the democrats did not win
the election
then you make a dollar which results in
a 50 force net profit otherwise the
contract expires worthless and you have
just lost your initial 46 cents
and now that we know how contracts on
predicted work
you know that whenever you buy any
single contract there is a possibility
that you win money
and there is also risk that you lose
your investment no matter how savvy you
might be about politics and this is
simply because your profit or loss
depends on element that are outside of
your control
wouldn't it be great if there was a way
to eliminate risk completely from the
equation and consistently make a profit
that's exactly where arbitrage comes in
when you do arbitrage you buy a
combination of contracts whose payoff
cancel each other out in a way that
leaves you with a positive profit no
matter what happens in the world
the last sentence was a mouthful so
let's start with a simple example
let's say you buy a yes contract and a
no contract at the same time
now i claim that you make one dollar no
matter what
this is because if the democrats win
your yes contract is going to give you
one dollar and if they lose your no
contract is going to give you one dollar
now let me ask you this
how much did you have to invest in both
of these contracts in this case
well it's 55 plus 46 cents which comes
up to one dollar and one cent
so with the strategy of buying aes and a
no contract at the same time we figured
out a way to take chance completely out
of the equation
you invest a dollar in a cent and you
are guaranteed to make a dollar in
return
the cynical amongst you might complain
here that this strategy although is
deterministic in its outcome
does not actually make a profit since it
loses one cent no matter what
i on the other hand like to keep a
positive mindset about things
the way i see it we are halfway through
our quest for arbitrage opportunities
we got the no risk part right but not
the profit part
and by the way note here that if by some
miracle you find a contract for which
the prices of es and a no sum up to
something less than one dollar
then you have just found yourself a
money making machine
and you can search all over the website
predicted for something like this but
unfortunately you wouldn't find any we
want to go into the details as to why
that's the case but this has something
to do with the way predicted matches
orders together in any case we are on
the right track here let's keep going
and try to think of another combination
of contracts whose payoff is guaranteed
and positive no matter what
let us jump to predict it again and look
at a different market this time
this market here is about who is going
to be nominated by the democratic party
to run for senator of florida there are
three candidates here
and the strategy we are going to explore
is to buy all the three yes contracts
here is a crucial observation
how much money would you need to buy
every yes contract well it's 93 plus
four plus one so 97 cents which is less
than one dollar when the market settles
and one of the three candidates become
the nominee the return from that
particular contract will be one dollar
so for each 97 cents you put in you make
3 cents in pure arbitrage profits and at
this point you might be tempted to stop
here and go celebrate finding your first
arbitrage opportunity
well not so fast
let's see what happens when i go ahead
and apply this strategy in real life
i'm going to buy one yes contract for
each candidate
and if everything goes according to plan
i should be making three sites
if i click here predicted in its
infinite generosity will show me my
potential profits that it has already
calculated for me
in this column you can see that we
bought one yes contract for each one of
the three candidates and in this column
you can see the prices that we bought
them for so far so good
this third column here which predicted
calls risk is our potential profit for
example
if you look at the first row this number
represents my profit in case demins wins
the nomination
uh-oh what's happening here
why is it showing only two cents and not
three cents like we computed something's
not right
let's keep going
if we look at the second and third row
predicted is telling me that not only i
want to make any profit
if grayson or murphy wins
but i will actually lose 7 cents why is
that
we obviously missed something
so as it turns out we neglected one big
aspect of markets that a lot of
beginners fail to take into account
which is fees
predicted actually takes ten percent of
your profit from any contract that you
bought
and you could say what's the big deal if
i can make three cents predict it will
take 10 percent of that so i still come
out ahead right
not quite
predicted takes 10 percent from the
profits of each contract individually so
for instance if demins wins the value of
this contract will jump to one dollar
resulting in seven cent profit and the
other two contracts will expire
worthless leaving us with a loss of
three and one cent respectively
so this will result in a three cent
overall profit like we computed before
and you might expect that predicted will
take 10 percent of that leaving you with
2.7 in profit but that is not correct
predicted will take 10 percent from each
contract that made you money so in this
case it will take 10 of the full 7 cents
leaving you with 2.3 cents instead of
2.7
and this is the number that predicted
showed us rounded to the nearest integer
and again this may not seem like a big
deal
but let's say it's grayson who wins
then this contract jumps to a dollar
resulting in 97 profit from this
contract alone
and these other contracts expire
worthless
so after predicted take its 10 percent
cut our overall profit goes from three
cents before feeds to a whopping minus
seven cents
hopefully now you get the idea the
cheaper the contract the bigger the
potential profit and the bigger the cut
of predicted gets
and now with fees in mind if you are to
look for a market where the buy all es
strategy is profitable what should you
be looking for
because of fees the condition that the
sum of the prices should be smaller than
one is not sufficient anymore we need to
take fees into account and as we have
seen the worst case scenario is when the
cheapest contract resolves to a yes and
mathematically this corresponds to the
following formula
and now this is a perfectly valid
strategy
you can go right now and try to find
markets that satisfy this condition but
before you do that however i should warn
you that there is something that you
should be aware of there is another
problem with the by all yes strategy
let me ask you this
what happens if a new candidate comes
out of nowhere and wins the nomination
what would happen is that all of our
contracts will become worthless and we
will lose all of our money
and this is a risk that will always
exist with the by all year strategy and
this is a big con and it can make this
strategy not very worthwhile not to
worry though because they have left the
best for less
the third strategy that we will see now
does not suffer from this problem
here are the strategies that we have
tried so far we have tried the strategy
of buying the yes and no version of the
same contract
and we have tried the buy every year's
contract in the same market
and as it turns out there is a better
strategy very similar to this one with
one fundamental difference
try to guess what that strategy might be
that's right instead of buying every
guess what if we bought every no instead
and to explain this strategy let's look
at the following market
who will be the governor of california
on december 31st
so let's imagine that we bought all the
no contracts and note that some no
contracts for some candidates don't even
have a price meaning that these
candidates are so unlikely to win
that it's not even possible to bet
against them so let's ignore those for
now and focus on the four main
candidates
and while we're at it let's also ignore
fees for now
so now let me ask you this how much is
our investment in this market and how
much are we guaranteed to win
the first question is easy our
investment is the sum of all the prices
so 2.94 cents
for the second question i claim that we
are guaranteed a return of at least
three dollars
this is because at most one of these
candidates will become governor so
before fees we should be making six
cents for each 2.94 we invest in this
market and let us now take fees into
account and see if we still come out
ahead for that
let's compute for each one of these
contracts our payoff if the value of
that contract jumps to one
and let's compute predicted 10 feet
on december 31st we know that the three
contracts that correspond to the three
candidates that did not win will pay us
each one dollar
so in the worst case we will pay about
10 cents in fees and our overall return
in this market will be three dollars
minus 10 cents which is 2.9
so overall we have a loss of about four
cents
it seems that this is a losing strategy
after all the hard work that we put in
we still came short
but here is an idea
who said that we should buy exactly one
of each contract
what if we buy a different number
say two of the first contract three of
the second 1.5 of the third etc
can we somehow make our profit positive
just by doing this
so let me play with the numbers here a
bit and at the same time let's track our
profit from this market
it seems that this particular
combination gives a positive profit
and while it's not possible to buy a
fractional number of contracts we can
simply multiply everything by 100 to
make the numbers round
and here i have to confess i didn't just
stumble upon these magical numbers that
made the math work i have actually used
this calculator that i have created
specifically for this video
it will give you exactly the number of
contracts that you should buy to
maximize your profit and in fact it does
a little bit more than that it can even
find for you the markets on predicted
where the by every node strategy works
best
i'll put a link in the description
let me now go on predicted and try that
and lo and behold after i've done all of
this predicted is now telling me that my
investment in this market is negative
one dollar as indicated by the
parentheses
and this means that no matter who is
elected governor we are guaranteed a bit
more than a dollar in pure arbitrage
profit and here is the kicker
since we bought only no contracts if a
new candidate comes in and sweeps the
election and unlike in the buy every yes
strategy we are not in danger of losing
our money anymore
in fact quite the opposite
if a new candidate wins then all four of
our no contracts will pay us each one
dollar so we actually make a bit more
than a hundred dollars in that case
and i hear some of you say that okay
sure we made one dollar here with a
small probability of winning 100
but you had to invest almost 300 of your
own money and leave it locked inside
predicted until december 31st so this
strategy clearly does not scale well
here is the thing though
and get ready because i'm about to blow
your minds predicted realizes that
mathematically we cannot lose money on
this trade
so it will actually give us our
investments back plus the one dollar let
me quickly play this video back and
let's watch exactly what happens to the
money that they have on my account it
starts to decrease initially and then as
i make more trades predicted realizes
that i cannot lose money so it gives it
back with benefit
and you know what i can do with that
money that predicted just give back to
me that's right i will go back and do
the exact same strategy again and make
another dollar
and i actually was lucky here that
prices had moved in my favor while i was
buying so i actually made 2.5 dollars
instead of just one dollar and again i
get my money back immediately and i will
do the exact same thing again
and again
i'll stop here but hopefully you get the
idea it's almost like a money-making
machine
i just made five dollars in pure
arbitrage profit with zero risk and zero
capital
so what is the cash
why am i not a billionaire yet
there are actually two good reasons for
that the first one is pretty
straightforward
predicted actually limits how many
trades you can make on any given market
you cannot put more than 850 on any
given contract
so if the price of a contract is 50
cents the maximum number you can buy is
1700 of that contract
the second and more fundamental reason
is that
as you start taking advantage of an
arbitrage opportunity prices will
eventually change and that opportunity
could disappear and you will need to
find a new one
i will end the video here
one important aspect we did not cover
here is automation
or how to write code that finds
arbitrage opportunities and creates them
in an autonomous fashion
maybe i will make a video about that in
the future
if you made it this far i want to say
thank you let me know in the comments if
you found this video useful and i will
see you in the next one
you